we you know we talk a lot about maybe
there was intentional maybe there are
reasons behind it i want to jump to this
next story which suggests
everything you've heard about the
problems trump faced may actually be a
result of trump derangement syndrome in
this tweet jackpot posted a video from
the trigonometry podcast shout out guys
from the trigonometry
sam harris quote hunter biden literally
could have had the corpses of children
in his basement i would not have cared
this is going viral like crazy
in since this morning 3.3 million views
sam harris basically says
that the the uh
what he calls a left-wing conspiracy to
suppress information to try and stop
trump from winning the presidency was
acceptable and good it was warranted and
constantine's like i i have to stop you
you're saying you're okay
with this manipulation to prevent
someone from winning a democratic
election and sam harris is like yup oh
he actually tracks back and says no no
no i i i i didn't you know i stutters a
lot of time let's play it let's play
let's play it
let me make sure i always have the audio
set to the wrong center yeah
all right here we go point hunter bind
literally could have had had the corpses
of children in his basement
i would not have cared right it's like
it's there's nothing
first of all it's hunter biden right
it's not it's like it's not joe biden
but
even if joe like even whatever scope of
joe biden's corruption is like if we
could just go down that rabbit hole
endlessly and and
understand that he's getting kickbacks
from hunter biden's deals in ukraine or
whatever else right or china
it is
infinitesimal
compared to the corruption we know trump
is involved in it's like it's like it's
like a firefly to the sun right i mean
like there's just it doesn't even it
doesn't even stack up against trump
university let me pause you right there
sam
let me just say something right now
trump university
trump university so so trump launched
university and may have uh his argument
defrauded a a handful of people into
giving up some cash and he's comparing
that to hunter biden on the board of
barisma joe biden's quid pro quo the war
that has erupted and is spreading across
the country the people who have died and
lost their cities joe biden sending
billions of dollars to the ukrainians so
when you're saying like maybe he's
getting kickbacks you know i don't know
who cares what's in the laptop
it is entirely possible that joe biden's
hunter entanglements are what's
exacerbating this conflict and you think
trump university is so much worse this
is the point i'm trying to get to
trump derangement syndrome is so intense
in these people's minds
what sam is saying makes literally no
sense if trump really is the con man
they think he is he's conned some
american people out of their money some
property owners and sure that's bad but
joe biden is conning the entirety of the
country to the world and putting us in a
very very precarious and dangerous place
with his inability to do his job and if
hunter biden really is involved in say
chinese private equity deals our
security is compromised well beyond
trump ripping off some fat woman who
bought a university ticket
i'm sorry man sam harris this stuff this
stuff lights me up let's play more
right trump university as a story
is worse than anything that could be in
in hunter biden's laptop insane right
what no that's not it doesn't answer the
people who say there's there's images
of hunter biden in the buff with family
members young miners yeah that have been
released from this
there there is he shares his bank
account his phone number with his dad
according to some reports he calls his
dad a pedo and trump university is worse
than anything let's play more
to not have looked at the laptop in a
timely way and to have shut down the you
know the new york post's twitter account
like that that's just a conspiracy
that's a left-wing conspiracy to deny
the presidency to donald trump
absolutely it was absolutely right but i
think it was warranted right and again
interested in democracy
you're saying you are content
with the left-wing conspiracy to prevent
somebody being democratically re-elected
as president well no i i'm conte well so
it's but the thing is it's just not
left-wing right so liz cheney is not
left-wing right oh man liz cheney is
doing everything in her policy to
prevent somebody from being democratic
it's not like no but there's nothing
conspiracy it's not it was a conspiracy
out in the open it does but it doesn't
matter if it doesn't matter what parts
conspiracy what parts out in the open i
mean i think it's like if people get
together and talk and talk about what
should we do about this phenomenon you
know if it's like if there was an
asteroid hurtling toward earth
and and we got in a room together with
all of our friends and had a
conversation about what we could do to
deflect its course right
is that a conspiracy you know like
someone
like that last 20 seconds is absolutely
flubber like he's not even making any
sense he said it was a left-wing
conspiracy to make sure that donald
trump didn't get democratically elected
and he was fine with it that's what he
said and then he walked it back and said
no it wasn't a conspiracy and it wasn't
left-wing like he just said it he just
said it sam this is an uh this is an
example of intelligence without wisdom
the guy
goes on these logical tirades which have
no emotional
integrity no no like
the the the saying is
intelligence is knowing that a tomato is
a fruit wisdom is knowing not to put in
a fruit salad and i think
right on from from ian it's the right
point sam harris is an intelligent guy
but he's he's it's it's
it's like it's a lack of emotional
control to say something as insane
wrong on moral and factual points is
just like
this is the danger i mean sam harris is
a very high profile guy with a very
large audience and he is a guy who goes
out and talks about the zealotry of
religious groups and how dangerous it is
and then look at what he says there's no
rhyme or reason to anything he was just
saying other than he's an authoritarian
who would use
by any means necessary powers to crush
people he doesn't like i think what
strikes him most is his last metaphor if
there was an asteroid coming to earth
and we made a plan to stop it that would
be okay right that's not a conspiracy
like he is so convinced that what's
happening with trump is just this
uncontrollable unpredictable force
he can't accept the fact that people
think differently than he does and they
want trump to be in office that they
don't agree with his perspective and
therefore he feels like he has the moral
authority to say like no you don't
understand this is like a devastating
crisis that we must act to stop
therefore democracy is not as important
in this moment like
it's bizarre the whole thing he said was
mishmash nonsense like like you
mentioned like the last 20 seconds
flubber walking back changing what he's
saying he's eats this is
constantine
is the trigonometry guys
they have values they have principles
they're they're in inquisitive they're
trying to understand things and this was
brilliant this is what real journalism
is this is not we don't get this from
brian seltzer we don't get this from cnn
this is him just literally saying okay
you've made your point
this is my question to you and then he
sends sam harris into a into a spiral of
nonsense yeah i mean i what they think
constant just the best is he has a
specific thesis he's trying to answer
which is like what can you do to defend
democracy where do you draw the lines
between what is acceptable and what is
not and
i don't think sam harris has the moral
compass to say like oh yes i respect how
democracy works like for him it doesn't
matter but what's
what do you think is causing this trump
derangement syndrome like look i
understand trump says mean things and
you might be like he lacks decorum but
to this degree
like
i think a lot of it has to do with
you know like he said
this dude's very intelligent
i mean he's super intelligent i i
appreciated him up until you posted this
on your twitter feed and it was like are
you kidding me that's crazy because it
it seems very deranged
but i think a lot of that is caused by
him living in an echo chamber he lives
in a bubble in an echo chamber he's used
to hearing the same people talk about
the same things and just as he refers to
the asteroid hitting the earth like
that's what he's correlating his
argument to like the worst case scenario
in the world
you're comparing it to that what i what
i think is fascinating like you
mentioned
is these two guys are actually being
journalists like and this is surprising
because it's like what is this thing
called like you know
objective reasoning on through
journalism like they're actually having
a conversation and he's willing to
confront sam harris on this and catches
sam harris off guard which i love
because like you said as soon as he
catches them off guard he starts going
down a a drain and he knows he's
circling the drain he's probably killing
time he's looking at the clock he's like
oh crap i don't know what to say you
know you know what this is
sam said the quiet part loud
not not realizing that he would be
challenged and that i think
what sam said is what he truly believes
in his heart of hearts yes
but
that is not something you can say
right now when you're trying to maintain
this
you know principal position of opposing
authoritarianism no he is an outright
authoritarian as so many of these
anti-trump people are what's the what's
the what's the big it's crazy
i see these people on facebook saying
you know trump's a fascist fire
authoritarian and so and they're saying
the same thing about ron desantis and
i'm like what have they done
trump wouldn't even bring in the
military to stop the rioting we watched
the writing go on all over the country
and trump said well i can't
man i'm sure a lot of people wished he
was more fascist and would have would
have stopped this rioting he didn't do
it
then you get antifa going around and
where is that accountability they get
propped up by the media and the
corporations they get defended they get
defended by cnn there's there's a
compilation daily why put out chris
cuomo is like the problem is not you
know the writers the problem is what
made your fellow man have to go out and
riot or something like that and it's
like no no dude these people are going
around and there's no rhyme or reason to
what they're destroying
this is exactly it
sam
there there was a viral tweet where a
guy was in beverly hills and he was
cheering on the riots and he was like
yeah riot woo
and then later on he tweets like why are
you coming to beverly hills stop don't
come here go downtown no no what are you
doing
they love it when they're watching these
people destroy other people's lives but
when it turns to them
jimmy dore i think i think i have a
tweet from jimmy dora
jimmy dore tweeted quote i'm for
censorship if it helps my side
politically i mean i just can't see a
downside to thinking like this because i
don't read history and i'm super smarter
than
you i see i'm stuttering like sam he he
he he didn't didn't he he didn't right
say exactly
how how sam right would say it
right he likes to do that right right
right like you agree with me agree with
and i think that's probably because he's
surrounded by people who are like no of
course we have to ignore the laptop that
makes sense like that's the only way to
stop the asteroid because that's what
they equate trump to i think that he
isn't
used to being pushed back i think maybe
he would have like i i don't know if
this happens on the show that often but
i think there are people who go on and
expect
to be interviewed in a very positive
sort of softball way they expect people
to be like oh yeah i get what you're
saying that makes sense thank you so
much for being here and i really you
know i applaud constantine for being
like we have to return to the thesis
which is that you would be willing to
like circumvent democracy yeah thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and we'll
see you all there